hey guys were here with the official
Deadshot character breakdown from
NetherRealm now this was taken from a
live stream so if you see anything that
seems a little off remember that it's a
work in progress and don't forget to
Like and subscribe to keep up to date
with all of our injustice to coverage
talk real quickly about what Deadshot is
Deadshot is the Zoners owner he is the
ultimate keep away projectile a
defensive character okay he is a just a
master of projectiles of his special
moves how many of them are projectiles
openings all but one
okay very good and the other one
arguably uses his own body as a
projectile okay let's see you're gonna
be 5 out of 5 now the thing is Floyd
Lawton does not miss ever he's the
world's greatest sharpshooter so it's
very good to have a bunch of projectile
moves if you if he's if he's if he's
dead
Steve nailed it Steve using all the
words today and some of them in the
wrong order
yeah alright so so let's go ahead let's
break it down I think before we get into
special moves oh let's talk about his
normal attacks because one thing I love
about him is he uses guns so effectively
even some of his normal attacks have
guns like his jump - it's a really good
advancing junkit jump attack this string
ends in a gun and you can actually hold
it down it's one two and then you can do
a quick one to restain them or you can
go the whole way and get a good chunk of
damage in an octave is down one is a
quick little poke it's actually a shot I
shot a little quick shot and then we can
see is four three
there's a heavy kick hey hey this is for
Drita's not involved it's not no button
Falls his boot right and I like his back
three it has a ton of range um he does
not really have high damaging mix-ups
but he does have a low starter it knocks
you away you can get a quick gunshot or
you can miss the gunshot and then he has
an overhead I thought he didn't miss ah
yeah when it comes back and gotcha
gotcha get him later he hasn't overhead
but he does not have a way to combo off
this unless uses a bar meter and it's
unsafe of blocked so he's kind of a high
risk low reward mix-up character but
then you get into a special moves
thanks for quite a toilet acting I'll do
is this we've always known the dare
caption control yes or this is not a
Superman interactable showcased air felt
like it was so he has a wrist shot which
is an extremely fast projectile travels
the full screen very very quickly and it
can meter burn it to do multiple shots
and the cool thing about this move is
you can hold forward to advance or you
can hold back to retreat so this we use
if you want to let's say you're up close
and you want to get away
you can retreat or you can use it up
close advance forward and then do short
little combos using the veins forward
then he has bullet barrage which is
instead of being a single shot it's
slower but it's multiple shots he's
going to turn around splash right this
one's flashing either the meter burn is
pretty decent Chuck and dates of barrage
it's a barrage it's literally a barrage
now if the risk hands aren't enough he
has a high-powered rifle on his back why
have it if you're not going to use it
right which is actually a low shot and
then you mean to burn it and this is one
of my favorite moves oh good a good
tough to beat the damage another great
thing about me to bartleburt me server
rifle is how good it is to keep people
so your art if they're already way too
good now let's say they're about here
and the opponent is blocking can you
block I can try
I've never seen on a wood please hold
down okay yeah the opponent actually
gets pushed away pretty far so if you
want to use the bar meter and make sure
your opponent's not going to be close
you know this is a move you can use to
push them away and then you can go back
to using your faster attacks so then to
really showcases aim he has trick shot
which is a shot you can control you can
do a close one far one and it's an
anti-air you can use it as a mix up tool
you can use it as a keep out tool you
can use it preventive ly you know let's
say the opponent's jumping in a lot you
can use it here oh and then the meter
burn one is very good the meter burn one
is great for his combo filler and just
totally you can't jump witness up like
this this part of the screen is totally
blocked off that creates a wall a wall
yeah so then is one special move that's
a melee attack is assassinate which is
an advancing safe on block a special
move toilet she also has a toilet he can
meter burn it to get good damage and a
knock
for wake-up setups throws people uh she
looks throws are very much I will say
when we have a new character that people
are working on their desks the first
thing I asked them is that they're
already yeah the same here say for me
the throw is the thing that like really
it kind of sets off their personality
yes the throw to me is the thesis
statement how the character is yes yeah
absolutely that's also one of the first
things I'll ask a designer right who's
the throat so Deadshot's pretty simple
you you basically your game plan is
gonna be shooting them shooting them
more and then shooting them again right
what happens if shooting doesn't work
then you do shooting someone for two and
two shooting yeah then they go away you
were shooting all right so he's
definitely an appeal if you're if you're
the kind of player that wants to stay
back keep them out frustrate the
opponent make them make mistakes and
then punish them for the mistakes now
when people get in on him there's he can
be a significant Asian yeah he's not
helpful so close like I said he does
have the back one and the four to mix
ups but it sure does our you want to be
right it's not he does have a good sweep
but it's not where Deadshot excels right
and you know he does have some decent
combo damage in the corner so he's not
helpless but it's not as ideal like if
you're if you like here's only like to
do like super huge swag swagg errific
combos he's probably not gonna be
favorite character right what if you
just want to sit back it'll buckle out
yes yeah definitely gonna be your kid
absolutely so let's talk about his
character power character power G has
three different ammo types that you can
load first he has incinerate bullets and
these will actually do extra damage
catch the opponent on fire and do dot
damage so you can see normally you know
he's only do just a little bit they're
mostly just a fast move to keep the
opponent out once he gets this on it's
just real damage sure the second
enhances distress game yes and and this
works on although even the normal
attacks will do this will get this
effect so then you can see he has
explosive rounds which turn blue and
these actually knock the opponent back
so a move that previously just staggers
them and gives you a little bit of
breathing room will not actually not be
pulling it down and you can see gives
you a lot of time needed uh kaboom yeah
these are all high and this is just the
risk cannon this is not the rifle and
then the last one is poison rounds which
turns green and this will actually drain
the opponent's super meter so check out
Superman suit
you can see he's actually losing a
pretty good amount of meter I just took
a bar and a half I would be so mad like
man so the idea here is you know
Deadshot's not the best character up
close and if you're afraid of a
character for example Superman who does
a ton of damage for using his ice breath
move you can remove the ability for him
to do the high damaging combos by
keeping him away with the poison wrap
right and the cool thing is once you
start loading ammo you'll see the bars
draining you can actually switch back
and forth so they go through the ham you
can cycle it through the ammo types
you're not just stuck with one so you
can use poison bullets take a little bit
of meter then go to the explosive
bullets now the opponent can't use for
example his meter but Superman punch to
get in and you can go to zoning out so
there's some definites of some to mind
games yeah there's a line exactly I
think you might have mentioned it out of
everybody heard the that's only rich for
only riff boys right correct it's only
risk cannibals
so these are not like you can't have
these two you're right you're correct
yeah cool right let's do a super huh all
right I like this I like to start up
Oh rad yeah
[Music]
and we're gonna be fine he'll be what I
love too is like keep mounting mount I
want to use my super got to get him I
forgot he also has the Erised can so
even even more air control so he can
really cut off every avenue the
opponents gonna have to commit to a
meter burn roll or a dash or an armored
special move to try to get in but you
trapped in the corner and he might be
half so issues yeah exactly
will excellent so we got a couple load
outs just looks and loadouts huh you
don't have to change mine it's okay you
always do I always do that yeah now it's
you that's cuz I'm a professional I want
it to be right professional look it's in
the book
alright so first off I really like this
gear that's good-looking I like the
color I like the rifle I like that his
wrist cannons turn into almost like
dragon yes alright so the first thing we
gave them is is rocket boost where you
actually used to this rocket looking
around the ground and then jumps forth
now you can use this to gain distance
quickly and you can actually attack from
like you can do a jump attack and go
into a jail of that now you'll notice
some really fun combos with it yesterday
we were should we go for it I think you
should you got something
well it took us a lot so no keep in mind
Steve is using the controller down not
being this is Steve credit tackle takes
need to do this coming up forever I'm
alright one more try okay you have three
tries three track retries three tries
oh that's the one that's deco that kinda
that counts would you count that if I
did it yeah yeah absolutely if I with
the potion did the boost we'd count yeah
it's true we're barefoot on part before
the actual way three that we were doing
last time well we're not we're not
showing that okay okay all right right
you're right you're right
and you'll notice one of the fun things
about this isn't a dead shot actually
takes a little bit of damage for using
haha I did not notice that which means
which means by the time the game comes
out to leave this year someone will
accidentally kill themself in tournament
with dead shot that has to happen oh
yeah
I wanted like you're so you play online
somebody good here move yeah once you
see that video yes and it will be placed
on top it will right pin back at the top
of the doesn't get yeah I want to stat
that we track yeah so this is a cool
move to use if you want to cover more
distance let's say you're fighting dr.
fate and his projectiles are just as
good as yours and you're like man I
really wish I had a way to get in close
really quickly there you go there it is
so then what if what if I told you he
had even more air control I wouldn't
believe you wouldn't believe me I don't
I believe you could you're kind of
setting it up all of you believe what if
I actually said no he doesn't well then
yeah you use that Debbie a weird setup
air rifle ooh
is instead of going straight like this
one it'll go down and the meter per 100
the goal thing is is I haven't seen so
yet cuz I was you guys sense the wall is
gone and this is super cool yeah like
doing the street rifle into the air
rifle to the rifle it is so super fun
yeah this this sound effects are
tremendous for these Bible and we have
one more load out I'm doing that to
spite you at this point fair enough
thank you and this one's one of my
favorites this is uh this is a shout out
to our injustice one players okay you
know there were a lot of injustice one
players that they loved to keep out game
it was one our favorite that's a good
point the Twitter chat is so anything
about damage right now this is a fully
loaded up dead shot version super this
is a fully loaded up set shot with all
epic gear right right and you did also
say that like gear in the tournament the
gear of course really moves aren't using
direct that's right so just okay and
also I mean just for you know just say
that hey this build is not the brand new
this just everybody to see they're gonna
change and tween calm down you're at a
ton you need to be the to em I said from
Steve never more relaxed so anyone who
lives at nine anyway the funnel ability
we'd like to show is a personal favorite
of mine low shots he's throwing them
bullet punching them low shots food oh
and my favorite thing about this one as
well
his gauntlets are called bullet poses
right Deadshot's bullet hoses low shots
so this replaces his low rifle and you
can see it is significantly faster it's
just as fast as a straight one so the
opponent has no choice but to be
conditioned to sit there and you know
this is definitely going to improve a
zoning co2 lithium yeah that's right you
will get less damage at less pushback
but the trade-off is this incredible
speed below another trade-off I don't
assume coming
right can you put your character on
these yes you can
so now they are character power as well
begins so sorry this will steal a lot of
bar now this one is very powerful but
this is what this is one of the two slot
moves which we talked about every week
that some of the more powerful ones are
two slots right cool
so I mean the zoning machine becomes a
even strong even stronger right alright
so what should we do next
I say we and here's the deal I like when
I we were planning the stream last week
I was like well maybe we do it on may we
do it on Friday mm-hmm and Steve was
like oh I can't hold be here